[Music]
bobsledding is a winter olympic sport
where you have your driver and you have
a brakeman which is my position the
brakeman is mainly the engine to the
sled we get it going as fast as possible
i am asia evans and i'm an olympic
bobsledder
[Music]
the track is about a mile long and full
of twists and turns and can get up to 90
miles an hour
the moment i zip up my speed suit i feel
like a complete superhero as almost like
i hear the theme music in my head i'm
ready to go
as we're going to the track picking up
speed we start to pull about five g's
which is five times the force of gravity
so it's literally what a fighter pilot
experiences
it's like someone's jumping on you
because out of nowhere you just feel all
this pressure on your lower back
it's a pretty noisy ride
my head is rattling throughout the sled
i'm trying to stay low
as soon as it's over i can inhale start
breathing again
this is one of the world's fastest
self-propelled sport
[Music]
the fastest skater will go over 50
kilometers per hour
to travel at such a high pace on the
eyes it feels that i can never get this
kind of feeling anywhere else
my name is lucas eung and i'm a short
track speed skater i have been skating
for over 20 years
but competitively only the recent 45
years
i compete with singapore but i'm right
now training in south korea
[Applause]
back in singapore a tropical country we
only have one ice rink and it's a public
ring so we only get two times of ice a
week whereas here in south korea i get
two types of ice in one day
i really like the culture of the people
here and how the whole system in the
sporting environment is
it allows me to understand the sport
better training alongside the koreans
who are the top athletes in this sport
as well
we train almost six to seven days a week
about five six hours a day pretty much
like a full-time job
it is quite a physical demanding spot
we'll do speed training we'll do
interval training we imitate the actions
and the movements on eyes and then we do
it on land so that we strengthen
the muscles needed
when i'm skating on ice it's a moment
where i feel that i'm in my own world
it feels that i have a lot of focus and
it's me and myself against the eyes and
against the speed that i'm trying to
achieve
[Music]
happy to have come so far and to have
met all the great people in the sport
and personally i feel that every time i
train and compete it makes me have this
adrenaline to want to work harder to
want to achieve greater
and not give up
[Music]
three two one see
bass jumping is already
the most dangerous sport in the world
then you're also mixing that with big
mountain skiing
you're combining full intensity sports
in an unforgiving environment the risk
factor is definitely pretty high
[Music]
hi matthias gero aka super frenchie i'm
a pro big mountain skier and
professional base jumper and i like to
put these two sports together
ski based jumping is skiing of a massive
cliff that would be too big to survive
and land safely so you use a parachute i
like to use my parachute as a tool to
ski things that i otherwise could not
ski i've been ski based swimming for 10
years and the last 10 years have been
filled with a lot of fun
the adventures i ski bass jump of the
eiger and also the meadow horn in
switzerland heavens 11 interior ride
i outran an avalanche by ski base
jumping of a 600 foot cliff
that was a pretty cool day do you see
that avalanche
fear is a it's an interesting thing your
instinct tells you okay stop right there
don't go any further this is the end of
the world right there this thing is
going to kill you this is the moment
when you have to take over and be no i'm
gonna jump off this thing and then you
come flying off this cliff
things get even faster and gnarier and
then the ground is coming straight at
you it feels like it's gonna eat you
then
the moment you land
oh man i love that time turn back look
at where you came from and then realize
that something super cool just happened
oh [ __ ] big man skiing and base jumping
is not forgiving i've definitely lost a
lot of friends over the years i've
almost died myself several times
you got to be on it you got to do the
right thing if you want to do it for a
long time that was a terrifying job it
was a close call but
hey i'm alive i'm not hurt
we did it we are looking for happiness
and some people find happiness through
balance and monotony and routine in
their life and for me that's honestly my
worst nightmare i seek happiness through
intensity
i think that intensity can bring the
best out of people
in the heart of downtown nairobi there
is a rink
that rink is home to an unnamed ice
hockey team currently
we haven't found a name for the team but
we just call it the kenya hockey team
[Music]
my name is bernard azeguere currently
the captain kenya is hockey league
i decided to play esoki simply because i
wanted to do something different
in kenya many people
we grew up playing different sports like
soccer athletics
i just want to do something that stands
out something unique
we have around 30 members in our team
we compete against ourselves
so whoever shows up we divide
the equal number of players
then we play against ourselves
[Music]
there's no money nice okay in kenya
unlike in europe where we have
leagues whereby
teams can buy players pay them well here
in kenya we're just beginning
in the next
coming years ice hockey will be a big
spot
currently many people are joining and
you're hoping to get even more as time
goes
[Music]
our future dream is for our kenyan team
to be featured in the winter olympics
i know we don't stand a chance
but
just
being there we might prove the world
wrong
once you achieve your dreams
there's a satisfaction
that comes with it
it's just a good feeling you're like
okay we've made it finally
[Music]
when i go down the slope it takes me
three seconds to get from zero to 60
miles an hour
i honestly can't explain what it feels
like even after 15 years of doing the
sport
[Music]
my name is sarah hendrickson and i'm an
olympic ski jumper
ski jumping is a sport where i go down a
two-track slope at 55 miles an hour
and when the slope ends i jump flying
about a football field in length in the
air
[Music]
when i'm getting ready to go the smell
is of the fresh air from the trees and
the snow in the area
and the feeling of cold brisk air on my
face
when i put my goggles on i know it's
time to go
[Music]
my eyesight when i'm going down the
slope is right in front of the tips of
my skis
my skis are bouncing up and down in the
track against the ice it feels like
clatter if you hear it it's like a
rumble
the flight takes three seconds but
honestly time slows down and it feels
like an eternity where i get to enjoy
flying
as i'm flying i can't hear anything it's
completely silent all around
the wind on my body feels like when you
put your hand out of a car window going
60 miles an hour moving it up and down
you can feel the lift and drag it has on
your hand
that's like ski jumping but for your
whole body
as i'm flying i'm totally alone i'm in
control of all my senses and all my
movements it's the best feeling in the
world
[Music]
you